greetings of peace welcome to our
channel the DS show before I get to
talking about all the wonderful topics
will be talking about on the show
subscribe right now
are you sick of feeling empty inside
there's a void in your heart you tried
everything to fill it with but you
haven't figured out the purpose of life
that's one of the major things we talked
about here in the D show and most
definitely we're gonna be talking about
Islam why not it's one of the hottest
topics that's in the world today and
we're going to be covering every
misconception that revolves around Islam
Islam stance on women terrorism jihad
you name it we're going to be striving
our best to talk about it here in the D
show subscribe right now
and also a wide array of many
contemporary topics party music and play
how does that fit into this way of life
did you know that Muslims love Jesus
will be talking about him too will be
talking about atheism and why stop there
we cover topics that have to do with
family sports nutrition a wide spectrum
of different topics that we cover here
in the D show subscribe right now
we thank god I've hunted a lot we've
been doing this over 10 years 500 plus
episodes and we bring on some of the
most amazing guests so we're going to
have a lot of fun cover a lot of ground
a lot of exciting topics you don't want
to miss out you want to be here every
Friday and then we'll try to give you
some short reminders in between but you
can't get that if you're not coming back
to the show every week Friday's will be
releasing it God willing inshallah
subscribe right now and enjoy all of the
content that we're going to be putting
out for you thank you peace be with you
sonam like and don't forget as I asked
you to do already if you have it
subscribe right now